as I said earlier tonight there are many
many changes coming up that that I'm
very excited about but to be really
honest and very frank there is one
change on the horizon that makes me
quite sad in January when our show
transitions to the new half-hour format
our band will not be with us and yes and
since we began this journey 25 years ago
my band has been a daily source of joy
in my life these remarkable musicians
have given their talent energy
enthusiasm and incredible showmanship
for over 4,000 hours these guys these
guys these guys played up my wedding
which was in Seattle in January and no
one goes to Seattle in January and they
came and they blew the roof off that
place and they have been with me through
all of the incredible highs and lows of
late night The Tonight Show and these
past eight years of TV s at the most
powerless moment of my career when I was
suddenly without a show and feeling
pretty alone this band came with me on a
nationwide tour that to this day is one
of the highlights of my professional
life they did purpose
and city after city they did then what
they've always done what they did
tonight they melted the audience before
I even set foot on the stage and you
don't see that at home
could they come out you don't see that
at home but they come out long before
the cameras are on and ERI and they
absolutely just bring the roof down and
and it sets up the show and they are
remarkable musicians and they're even
better people there is no better
testament to their generosity of spirit
than the fact that every day every
single day at rehearsal
they have generously let me play guitar
with them and endured my torturously
slow progress I have no idea if I'm a
better comedian now than I was in 1993
but thanks to these guys I'm definitely
a better rhythm guitarist it is
something it is it's something
I take this stuff seriously I'm a
student of late-night television I've
looked at all the shows going back to
the 1950s and I can say this with
confidence
I've been graced with the most versatile
loyal and joyously effervescent band in
the history of television and to put it
very simply
to put it very simply I love these guys
so tonight on our last hour-long show
I'm putting a spotlight where it belongs
on Jimmy Vivino
and the basic-cable band gentlemen I
want to thank you for a quarter century
of friendship laughter and the best
music I will know in this life it's all
here is Jimmy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you